one of the really striking things about
the attack on the Charlie Hebdo magazine
is that it has been conducted clearly by
people who are both military
professionals and I'll wager have combat
experience they have killed in the past
now this is very very different to the
sort of self-starter so-called lone wolf
attacks that we've seen on the streets
of London with the murder of Lee Rigby
using kitchen utensils or indeed recent
attacks inside France where people have
used vehicles as weapons
this is using old fashioned infantry
tactics to cause mayhem on the streets
of Paris now let's have a look at the
first piece of video footage now I'm
going to stop it just before the firing
starts the two individuals who've exited
this this this car are these are the two
terrorists two of the three terrorists
they are moving in what's called mutual
support of one another they're spaced
out and they're slightly staggered one
is further forward than the other but
both of them are mounting their weapons
correctly they're taking I aim down the
sights they're not spraying they're not
firing from the hip because their target
further down the street is a policeman
each one of those shots we just heard
has been individually fired off it's
been carefully pulled that's called an
aimed shot it's not fired on automatic
again a sign of professional training in
the heat of the moment less well trained
people start firing an automatic they
get frightened they get excited their
victim is a policeman we blurred out the
image of him he's lying on the ground
he's got his hands in the air now the
two gunmen approach and this is the
striking thing there again are moving in
mutual support
now we paused it at the point just
before the gunman in the far ground
actually execute he murders the
policeman on the street but he does so
without breaking stride he does it at a
job with a familiarity with his weapon
and a coldness that to me at any rate
indicates that this man has killed
before they then move on down the street
check that they're safe and then start
moving back to their vehicle now they're
just in the background this gunman is
Maven some hand signal saying that's it
wrap up that's a signal that in broad
terms means regroup get back to the
vehicle he's signaling to the guy behind
him job done let's get out of here now
in the second video we see a similar
level of mutual support but this is an
infantry but maneuver known as moving in
bounds when people leapfrog one another
so there we see a gunman at the junction
in the street there he's gone forward we
know from other camera angles that we've
looked at that this actually shows that
the two gunmen moving forward an opening
fire at a police car but at this moment
we have one gunman Ford and one is just
emerging from next to his car
now the first gunman opened fire and
then he's joined by the second one the
second one is bounding forward in that
standard infantry way and then they both
withdraw again facing towards where they
perceived the threat may come and they
go back to their car and the chilling
moment here is that back at their car
they're extremely calm again that would
indicate that they're not overexcited
that they've got control of their
adrenal reactions in this fight or
flight environment and that they're
pretty relaxed they've done this before
when people are learning to use weapons
especially automatic weapons they tend
to jump around they've got a big kick
and they're a bit frightening people
close their eyes and so the bullets tend
to spray all over the place it takes a
degree of training and a degree of
experience to fire accurate shots when
under pressure let alone when faced with
combat in this case we see a police
vehicle that's got a very tight grouping
of probably shots fired on DoubleTap
that's when two shots are pulled off
almost simultaneously but after careful
aiming they're all in a very similar
area now this may have been a relatively
short range but with an ak-47 that tends
to leap in the air this is a clear
indication that somebody has proper
weapons training and is confident